this is the National Palace of Culture
in central Sofia and polygon OVA
suggested it as a meeting place she
spends a lot of her leisure time here at
concerts or on the footbridge behind the
building
so this bridge here what kind of pace is
it this is the lovers bridge we call it
because we call it that because everyone
wants to make his date here it looks
like quad romantic and evening if it's
really beautiful because you see just
sliding a little little Lighting's
everywhere
Sofia has more than 1.2 million
residents it's one of Europe's oldest
cities although there is not much left
from antiquity many historic buildings
were destroyed during the Communist era
time for some shopping Polly Unova takes
Misha to her favorite store in the heart
of town this is where we met the singer
for the first time two years ago back
then she just represented Bulgaria in
the Eurovision Song Contest
she took us to a trendy cafe that looked
like a cross between a tea shop and
someone's living room and showed us her
music video
she was buoyed up by her success but she
was aiming for more since then her
schedule has become chock full yesterday
a concert today a musical tomorrow a
shoot for her latest video so of course
she needs plenty of new outfits so what
is it you are looking for what kind of
dress um something very untypical as you
see very unique next stop the
hairdresser
in addition to our clothes polygons OVA
is known for her conspicuous hairstyles
you have a lot of fans that dressed like
you that copy our style oh yes
especially the haircut the teenagers
love the shape-shifting and try to do it
today she's getting hair extensions and
the stylish gives Misha a new look -
yeah
next stop the National Music Theatre
where Polly Geneva is playing the role
of Princess Jasmine in the musical
Aladdin alongside her music and acting
career she studying film but despite her
immense workload
she's very relaxed her big moment
arrives
the 26 year old seems tireless after two
and a half hours on the stage she still
has time for her fans since taking part
in the Eurovision Song Contest Palicki
Nova has been a star in Bulgaria how
important was the the Eurovision Song
Contest for your career here in Bulgaria
very very important because it opens the
every door I wanted to open for example
I wanted to to be a post and a big show
I was I wanted to be an artist in the
teacher I am now I want to have for my
first album and I will have it and she's
still got enough energy for an evening
on the town with some friends things
kick off at the vasila CeeLo restaurant
and it's one of polygon OVAs favorite
eateries it features real Bulgarian
cuisine and that means meat meat and
more meat
Poli gay Nobel Prizes the restaurant for
its colorful entertainment Misha gets
the chance to learn a traditional
Bulgarian dance
we end the day with a stroll through the
city at midnight poll Iggy Nova says
good night the busy career girl has to
be out of the house at 6:00 in the
morning
you